- [Instructor] Hello, everyone.
Today, we're going to be talking
about galaxies and gravity.
We know the Earth is a planet
that is in orbit around the sun.
This is called the heliocentric model.
And the solar system is
an enormous space for us,
encompassing every place that humans
or our robots have ever been.
But it's actually quite
small, cosmically speaking.
Even our furthest spacecraft, Voyager 1,
has only traveled less
than 0.1% of the distance
to the nearest star.
Our solar system is just a small component
of a much, much larger set of structures.
The sun is just one star
of hundreds of billions
of stars in our galaxy, which
is called the Milky Way.
And our galaxy is one of several
dozen in our galaxy group,
which is called the Local Group.
Other galaxies might belong
to larger collections
that are called galaxy clusters.
Now the same thing that
holds Earth in its orbit
around the sun is what holds together
massive groups and clusters
of galaxies: gravity.
This is the same as the
gravity that makes a ball
fall back to the ground when
you toss it up into the air.
Gravity is a force that operates
between two objects that have mass
and tries to pull them closer together,
whether those objects
are a ball and the Earth
or two galaxies.
Now the strength of this
pull depends on two things.
First is the mass of both objects.
So as either object gets more massive,
the strength of gravity increases.
For example, you have a
lot more mass than a ball.
So the force of gravity
between you and the Earth
is pulling harder than
the force of gravity
between a ball and the Earth,
and that's why it's a lot harder
to throw you into the air than a ball.
Gravity also depends on the distance
between the centers of the objects.
As the objects get farther apart,
the strength of gravity decreases.
For example, if there is a
ball on top of Mount Everest,
the pull of Earth's gravity on
it is actually slightly less
than the pull of gravity on
that same ball at sea level,
because the top of the
mountain is farther away
from the center of the Earth.
Now, this is a very small effect,
less than a percent difference,
because the difference between
sea level and mountaintop
is still very small
compared to the distance
to the center of the Earth.
But that's just on Earth.
We know that things in
space are really far apart.
The Earth is almost 93 million miles,
that's 150 million
kilometers, from the sun.
So if gravity is weaker when
objects are farther apart,
then in order for gravity to
be keeping these structures
bound together, they must be
really massive, and they are.
The sun has a mass of about
two nonillion kilograms.
That's 10 to the power of 30.
And the Milky Way galaxy,
which is about a quintillion
kilometers in diameter,
has a mass of about 1.5
trillion times that of the sun.
So thanks to their high masses,
objects like our Milky Way
galaxy and our nearest neighbor,
the Andromeda galaxy, which
are the two largest galaxies
in the local group, can be
pulled together by gravity,
even across millions of light years.
In fact, gravity between our
two galaxies is so strong
that it's actually pulling the Milky Way
and Andromeda galaxies together
into an eventual collision.
But eventually in this case
means almost 5 billion years
from now, so no need to worry.
To review, in this video
we covered how the Earth
is part of the solar system
and our solar system is part of a galaxy,
and our galaxy is part of a group.
Galaxy groups, galaxies and solar systems
are all bound together by the
same force, that of gravity.
Gravity is a force which
tries to pull objects
with mass closer together and it is weaker
for less massive objects or for objects
that are farther apart.
Thanks for watching
and I hope you learned a
little bit of something.